[Music]
Peter King kind enough to join us Pete's
on the road he is uh was uh in San
Francisco he was there with the Lions
and the ners and uh you stayed there are
you uh it's uh it's early out there Pete
uh it's dark out there yeah where are
you yeah I'm on my way to I'm on my way
to do a story out here with the 49ers
before I come back home to New York and
the only way I could do it
unfortunately is by doing something very
early this morning and then I realized
when the Great Todd Fritz asked me to be
on the show I said this is going to be
dark out here where I am so anyway sorry
about this
weirdo uh you know this weirdo look this
morning Dan hello darkness my old friend
glad to have you glad to have you there
uh can you tell us what you're doing
with the
49ers I really can't but it's not any
deep dark secret I just am not going to
say anything until the column comes out
next week okay uh what was your takea
away from the Lions perspective a few
days you know removed from
it well I I kind of split the baby on
this Dan I think that Dan Campbell was
fine in going for it on Fourth and two
on his first Series in the third quarter
for a very simple reason that they had
obliterated the San Francisco defense in
the first half and they were playing
great and on this particular Drive they
had taken it down the field 47 yards the
49ers as of yet had not stopped them and
so it's Fourth and two and you say hey
we could be ahead 31 to1 let's do it
let's go for it so I don't have a
problem with that because remember I
mean the reason why we're all talking
about this honestly is is in large part
because of jir gibbs' fumble you know
basically right after the 49ers score to
make it
2417 the second one I have a real
problem with because you're down with 7
minutes and 36 seconds to go
2724 you have a 48 yard field goal and
Dan when I meet when I tell you that
being in that stadium that that day that
night it was an absolutely beautiful day
and the weather was Zero Factor at the
time of that kick it was probably 65
degrees may you know no wind and you
know so I don't know a field goal kicker
should be able to make a 48 yard field
goal especially especially when you
consider that if you're the Lions you
have to think to yourself we're only
gonna get the ball one more time that's
it we gotta tie this game and then we
our defense has got to make a stop so
that's how I look at those two things
you've been in so many locker rooms uh
over the year like I have secondhand
pain for the Lions I'm not invested in
the Lions but I feel I feel for that fan
base and Dan Campbell and everybody
because they may not get back here can
you remember going into a locker room
that had sort of a similar feel
well the unfortunate thing is I didn't
go into the Detroit locker room uh after
the game uh but obviously there was
Devastation in there um and and look I I
think the one game that I thought of
that the the G the the two teams were
just like distra or the team was
distraught after the game was the Giants
when they lost to the Bears in Chicago
on the Sha leetta whiffed punt now you
got to be a person of a certain age to
understand that and to remember it right
Dan but I think honestly if you remember
that moment you remember going into that
locker room after the game that the New
York Giants would be fried and they were
talking to Peter King he's joining us
somewhere in the Bay Area and uh by
candl light here it's a it's like The
Blair Witch Project uh Peter where yeah
yeah I should have thought of that it's
a great one Dan I should have thought of
that the Ravens loss it feels like is
being overshadowed by the Lions should
it
be man that was a bad game for the
Baltimore Ravens it was a bad game in so
many ways how many veteran guys on the
Ravens made absolutely stupid plays and
look you know you're competing out there
and I understand it but Kyle vanoi is 32
years old he's one of the smartest guys
you know on on that on that team and he
headbutts Travis Kelce I mean how
foolish is that ran Smith the defensive
leader of that team $20 million a year
man you know the the centerpiece of that
defense this Generations Ray Lewis he's
not as good but that's what he's asked
to do and he not only jumps offside
which which would be understandable but
he plows over a guy and gets a 15 yard
penalty I mean those things are just
not possible not tolerable and that's
what would really bother me and and look
Lamar Jackson's throwing into triple
coverage and again I'm not in any way
dismissing that horrible
decision but he's trying to make a play
you know when nothing is going right for
his team but
overall this is
another uh Mark in the column of Lamar
Jackson's not very good in the playoffs
he has had one great half in six playoff
games that's just not good and and I
know everybody will have different
reasons for it and all that stuff but
you know at the end of the day Dan he's
been overall a lousy playoff quarterback
and that can't be erased by two MVPs
if I would have told you 30 years ago
Vegas would hold the Super
Bowl what would you have said yeah hey
if you had told me 20 years ago eight
years ago I would have said you're out
of your mind it'll never happen but the
NFL got in bed with the gambling
interest everybody's in bed with the
gambling interest now everybody it's not
just the NFL and it's not just every
Sports League it's every Media company
now yeah
so what do you what what do you expect
honestly what do you expect the NFL is
going to play a Super Bowl in Las Vegas
it's totally insane to think about it
but again that's the way our country is
going right now yeah I I just worry
because you know Commissioner Goodell
was anti-gambling in
2015 and I course he was I don't know if
anything changed other then they
realized what their piece of the pie was
going to be and these other leagues
realize their piece of the pie and what
it was going to
be Dan honestly it's the one the one
reason why you can't blame the leagues
quite
honestly the one reason is very simple
is
that the the legal system in our country
the judicial system in our country said
gambling's fine go ahead all you States
you make your own rules on gambling now
you make your own laws it's up to you
and so now we have uh legalized Sports
gambling in how many states in the
country I don't know at least 20 and so
you know that is what happened but the
NFL uh not
only uh you know embraced gambling it's
gotten full on into bed with gambling
and if if you can make money on it the
NFL sniffs it out and figures it out
I want you to place bill bellich in a
media
job where would it be what would he
do I mean Rich Eisen had the best take
when I talked to him the other day it
was he said how about a coach cast with
Nick Sabin where they go and stream on
uh whatever either fox or or Paramount
Plus or peacock or maybe even Amazon
Prime you know they they they fig figure
out a way for bellich and Sabin to work
together very light liting and bellich
could sort of change the narrative on
who he is and what a d you know
sour uh antagonistic human being he is I
think he needs to do that because look
if you're gonna hire a coach next hiring
cycle and understand that when Bill
bellich takes the sideline for your team
he's going to be 73 years and 5 months
old well you better think that you're
hiring a guy who you can get along with
because at the end the crafts really
didn't get along with Bill bellich and
and so he's got to change the narrative
on who he is yeah I'm wondering you'd
have to have a a strong host with Sabin
and bellich because they'd have to kind
of get you in and out of segments there
it couldn't be like the Mannings but I
could could see where those two guys and
their friends have them uh you know dish
on games um but also I was wondering
here was one we were talking about you
know Greg olssen has done a really good
job with Fox this year yeah I'm
excellent okay why why don't can you
monetize Brady in the studio more than
you can with him just being at a
game I don't know that Dan I'm a little
dubious about that because you know if
you were one of six people in a
studio is that worth for an hour of a
pregame show and some of a postgame show
is that worth the same as when 56
million people are watching your game
and watching you I don't know what the
ratings are for the pregame shows but
let's say it's what is it I don't know
eight or 10 million I don't even even
know but it's not huge because there are
so many of them and so the fact is I
think it'd be hard to monetize that if I
were
Fox I wonder if you could put Brady in
with
Olen and maybe do a little uh hybrid a
little combo platter
there maybe you know the three-man booo
is a totally different animal yeah and
who knows maybe Fox will decide to do it
but
I think what happens then is you have
the guy who's making what did he make
this year 10 million I don't even know
what what I I shouldn't even say what
did he make 10 Mill I don't know what he
made but Brady obviously is making
whatever it is 37 million and it would
kind of seem absurd that the guy who
everybody right now thinks is one of the
best or the best making a quarter of of
what the big star is making yeah and out
shining him in the booth it would just
seem pretty weird to me yeah I I wonder
we have Greg Olsen on the show tomorrow
but um I thought that he did a you know
really really good job in simplifying
the game and I thought he had a really
good performance over the weekend we
were just wondering if you put Brady in
the studio let's say Fox's Studio there
uh people want to see Tom Brady it's not
I don't know if it's necessarily want to
hear him but see him in the studio we'll
find out yeah we'll find out and Dan I
think the other thing is I don't know
who actually
pays who looks at a game and says I'm
gonna watch this I'm more eager to watch
this because I love the analyst of the
game I I mean maybe some people did that
with John Madden I don't know but I tend
to think that the vast vast vast
majority
are going to tune in if Boo the clown is
the analyst on the
game well I'm wondering about that too
if you got 56 million that watch the
game it's you know does Tom Brady bring
more to that or if I put him in the
studio you're going to watch the pregame
maybe more and then you'll stay tuned
for halftime and then you'll stay tuned
for the post game as well like that
would be something that I think you
could say Brady is getting an audience
keeping audience more than you know
who's broadcasting the
game maybe but just Dan imagine if you
are Fox right now and you go to Tom
Brady and say hey I know you've been
working for the last six months and
doing a lot of practice broadcasts and
you've been going around the country and
meeting with different people and really
honing your craft when you become an
analyst at a game site and imagine fox
goes to him now and said uh we want you
to be in the studio if I'm Brady I'm
saying a no B you got still got to pay
me what I'm worth because this is not
what you hired me to
do what would a Super Bowl win mean for
Patrick
Mahomes I mean he's already had an
absurd career he's already had the kind
of career that onethird of the way
through it that I'm pretty sure he'd
make the Pro Football Hall of Fame if uh
you know two weeks from now he never
stepped on a football field again but
what what it would mean is it would
accelerate his process in winning a
third Super Bowl to basically competing
with Tom Brady uh to be the best ever
because clearly if you win a third Super
Bowl in your first six
years that's an absurd start to your
career and again look Brady had sort of
two careers he had that first half you
know when he won three Super Bowls then
he had a drought and then he won three
more so I I don't know what it would do
other than to just sort of put an
exclamation point on what everybody
already thinks of him which is that he's
got a very good chance of going down is
the best of all time what would a Super
Bowl do for Brock
pie he's already an incredible story and
I think if he wins this game I mean
maybe
possibly could be you know we'll shut up
all the people who think the 49ers are
winning in spite of Brock pie which is
so ridiculously insane you know and I
hate the whole Analytics element that
that basically gives that
breath because a guy who's the
quarterback of a winning football
team you can't make excuses for that he
has a lot to do with it he doesn't have
everything to do with it and he has an
incredible Supporting Cast but let me
ask you this question how great is Jared
golf Supporting Cast it's probably the
best supporting cast of Any quarterback
in football and yet everybody talks
about oh man gof is really taking his
game to the next level I mean at some
point you're going to have to and again
look Brock P's had his hiccups this year
there's no question about it but you
know every quarterback does and I just
think the second half he played in that
game and how he's played overall in his
first whatever 25 28 games in the NFL it
really should be enough for people now
but for some it isn't great to talk to
you Pete thanks for joining us and uh
safe travels
back thanks so much Dan appreciate it
that's Peter King on the road doing
something
secretive what could it be what could it
be for Peter we're going to find out
next Monday the football morning in
America column